This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Here on the show there's a fall tradition we love. It has nothing to do with pumpkin spice or Halloween, although we love those too. What I'm talking about is the annual announcement of the winner of the Nobel Prize in Economics. The Royal Swedish Academy of Sciences has decided to award the Sverius Riksbank Prize in Economic Sciences in Memory of Alfred Nobel to Richard H. Thaler. Richard Thaler has played an outsized role in shaping the field of behavioral economics. He also happens to be a great conversationalist. So we thought we'd revisit our 2015 conversation with him. it's still one of our favorites.
这里是“隐藏的大脑”，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。在我们的节目中，有一个我们非常喜欢的秋季传统。这与南瓜香料或万圣节无关，尽管我们也喜欢那些。我说的是每年诺贝尔经济学奖得主公布的时候。瑞典皇家科学院决定将纪念阿尔弗雷德·诺贝尔瑞典银行经济学奖授予理查德·H·塞勒。理查德·塞勒在塑造行为经济学领域发挥了巨大的作用。碰巧他也是一位出色的健谈者。所以我们想重温我们在2015年与他的对话，这仍然是我们最喜欢的对话之一。
Richard Thaler's latest book is Misbehaving, the Story of Behavioral Economics. I spoke to him before a live audience at NPR's Weekend in Washington, an event that brings together public radio supporters from across the country. I want to start by asking Richard a real softball question. Your friend, whose name is Daniel Coniman, he won the Nobel Prize in Economics some years ago, a well-famous psychologist, brilliant author, and Danny Coniman was once asked to describe Richard Thaler to a journalist.
理查德·塞勒的最新书是《错误的行为：行为经济学的故事》。我在NPR的“华盛顿周末”活动现场的观众面前采访了他，这是一个汇聚了来自全国各地的公共广播支持者的活动。我想以一个真正简单的问题开始问理查德。你的朋友名叫丹尼尔·卡尼曼，他几年前获得了诺贝尔经济学奖，是一位著名的心理学家、杰出的作家，丹尼尔·卡尼曼曾被要求向一位记者描述理查德·塞勒。
And he said that Richard's dominant characteristic, the thing that makes him stand out is that Richard is lazy. Can you tell me Richard, why Danny said that, and also why he insists that this was a compliment? Yeah, what's worse is a Danny is my best friend and B. He said this was my best quality. To this day Danny defends this and that he defends A that it true and B, that it's a compliment, because he says that it means I'm only willing to work on things that are important.
他说理查德最突出的特征，让他脱颖而出的事情是理查德很懒。你能告诉我理查德为什么丹尼尔会这么说，以及为什么他坚持认为这是一个赞美吗？是的，更糟糕的是，A，丹尼尔是我的最好朋友，B，他说这是我最好的品质。直到今天，丹尼尔还在为这一点辩护，他辩护说，A，这是真的，B，这是一个赞美，因为他说这意味着我只愿意做重要的事情。
The truth is, I'm only willing to work on things that are fun, and that's why I'm here today, because I think we're gonna fun. I think that's exactly right. So I first started talking to Richard maybe about 10 years ago. Let me just ask you to give us a very short introduction. What is behavioral economics? And why has it made such a splash?
事实是，我只愿意做有趣的事情，这就是为什么我今天在这里，因为我认为我们会玩得很开心。我认为这完全正确。所以我大约在10年前开始和理查德交谈。让我请你给我们做一个非常简短的介绍。什么是行为经济学？为什么它引起了这么大的轰动？
Or why has it been so controversial over the last 15 or 20 years? How is it different than garden variety economics? You know, probably sometime in your distant past, all of you have had a class in economics. And you know that standard economics assumes that people are highly rational creatures capable of complex calculations, devoid of emotion, never having any self-control problems, and they're complete jerks. So I call these fictional creatures e-cons. That's short for homo-economicists, the Latin term.
或者为什么它在过去15或20年里一直如此具有争议？它与普通的经济学有什么不同？你知道，可能在你们遥远的过去的某个时候，你们所有人都上过经济学课程。你知道标准经济学假设人类是高度理性的生物，能够进行复杂的计算，没有情绪，从来没有自我控制的问题，而且他们是彻头彻尾的混蛋。所以我称这些虚构的生物为“经济人”。那是拉丁语“经济人”的简称。
And I believe that for the last 50 or 60 years, economists have devoted themselves to studying fictional creatures. They might as well be studying unicorns, because there are no e-cons. Well, there are a few economists I know who are close, but basically they don't exist. And so we have very fancy models of fictional creatures.
我相信在过去的50或60年里，经济学家们一直致力于研究虚构的生物。他们还不如去研究独角兽，因为根本没有“经济人”。好吧，我认识的一些经济学家很接近，但基本上他们不存在。所以我们有关于虚构生物的非常奇特的模型。
And the people I know have trouble figuring out how to divide a check if there are more than three people. I occasionally, just occasionally, overeat or over drink, have trouble saving for retirement. And contrary to economic theory, some at least are willing to donate to National Public Radio,
而我认识的人如果有多于三个人，在分账单时都会遇到麻烦。我偶尔，只是偶尔，会暴饮暴食或喝多，在为退休储蓄时遇到困难。与经济学理论相反，至少有些人愿意向美国国家公共广播电台捐款，
which any economist will tell you is a completely irrational thing to do, because you can listen to it for free. So. So. Okay. So when I first started talking to Richard about 10 years ago, it was for a topic that was called mental accounting. And Richard explained to me that mental accounting is something that we all do in everyday life.
任何经济学家都会告诉你，这是一件完全不理智的事情，因为你可以免费收听它。所以。所以。好的。当我大约10年前开始和理查德交谈时，是为了一个叫做心理账户的主题。理查德向我解释说，心理账户是我们日常生活中都会做的事情。
And one of the things that I noticed is that as soon as Richard started talking, I started thinking of examples from my own life where mental accounting was playing a really, really big role. Let me just start by having you tell us where mental accounting was playing a really, really big role. Let me just start by having you tell us what mental accounting is, Richard. So a basic concept of economics is that money is fungible, which means that there are no labels on it. There's a video of Dustin Hoffman and Gene Hackman talking and Gene Hackman's telling this story about when they were young actors. Hackman goes to visit Dustin Hoffman in his
我注意到的一件事是，理查德一开始说话，我就开始联想到我自己的生活中，心理账户在其中发挥了非常非常大的作用。让我先请你告诉我们，心理账户在哪里发挥了非常非常大的作用。让我先请你告诉我们什么是心理账户，理查德。经济学的一个基本概念是金钱是同质的，这意味着上面没有标签。有一个达斯汀·霍夫曼和吉恩·哈克曼交谈的视频，吉恩·哈克曼在讲述他们年轻时的演员故事。哈克曼去帕萨迪纳拜访达斯汀·霍夫曼的
little apartment in Pasadena. Dustin Hoffman has asked him to borrow some money and then Hackman goes into his kitchen and he sees these Mason jars that have labels on them and one is rent and one is utility. And there was nothing in the jar labeled food. And so you don't need any money, you've got lots of money in all these jars. And Hoffman says, yeah, but there's nothing in the food jar. And so that's mental accounting, right? And it used to be like certainly in my
小公寓。达斯汀·霍夫曼向他借了一些钱，然后哈克曼走进厨房，看到这些贴有标签的梅森罐，一个写着房租，一个写着水电费。而贴着食物标签的罐子里什么也没有。所以你不需要任何钱，你在所有这些罐子里有很多钱。霍夫曼说，是的，但是食物罐里什么也没有。所以这就是心理账户，对吧？过去，肯定在我的
grandparents generation that that's literally how people did it. But we still do it mostly in our heads. And it can make us do all kinds of funny things. So one of the things that's happened over the years is that Richard has actually played a psychotherapist for many people who come to him with their economics problems. And I'm actually going to do the same thing here. One of the things I've noticed about myself is that my wife and I, we share our finances. So we have a joint checking account, we sort of draw from the same pool of money. But I've noticed that when I go to restaurants,
祖父母那辈，人们真的是那样做的。但我们仍然主要在脑海中这样做。这会让我们做出各种各样有趣的事情。所以多年来发生的事情之一是，理查德实际上扮演了许多带着经济问题来找他的病人的心理治疗师。我在这里实际上也要做同样的事情。我注意到自己的一件事是，我和妻子共享财务。所以我们有一个共同的支票账户，我们从同一个资金池中支取。但我注意到，当我走进餐馆时，
I really like it when my wife pulls out her credit card and pays for the bill. Now, I am effectively still paying for it, but it significantly increases my satisfaction with the meal, not to have to pull out my own credit card. OK, so all right. So here's something that would be even better. Assuming you and your wife trust one another,
我真的很喜欢我妻子掏出信用卡支付账单的时候。现在，实际上依然是我在付钱，但这显著增加了我对这顿饭的满意度，因为不用掏出我自己的信用卡。好吧，所以。好的。所以这里有一个甚至更好的主意。假设你和你的妻子彼此信任，
I recommend that you each get separate checking accounts. What? No, you can still have a, my wife and I have this arrangement. So we each have a separate checking account and a joint checking account. And splurges, if I buy myself a new set of golf clubs that I desperately need, or she buys her fourth camera because she travels the world taking pictures, I don't see that.
我建议你们各自开设独立的支票账户。什么？不，你仍然可以有，我和妻子就是这样安排的。所以我们各自有一个独立的支票账户和一个共同的支票账户。至于大手大脚的花费，如果我给自己买了一套我迫切需要的新高尔夫球杆，或者她买了自己的第四个相机，因为她环游世界拍照，我不会看到那些。
So the splurges come out of your individual checking account? Exactly. And gifts. So if your wife picks up the tab, it will come from her account. That's even better. That's really a good idea. And I mean this is a recipe for a marital harmony. One of the findings of mental accounting is that people keep tabs in their head about how much money they need to make on an annual basis or a monthly basis, or even sometimes on a daily basis. And one of the things that you explained to me was this might explain why it's sometimes difficult to catch a cab on a rainy evening. Can you tell us why mental accounting might make it harder for us to catch cabs on rainy
所以大手大脚的花费是从你们各自的支票账户里出的？没错。还有礼物。所以如果你妻子买单，这会从她的账户里出。那甚至更好。这真的个好我的意思是这是婚姻和谐的秘诀。心理账户的一个发现是，人们在脑海中记账，关于他们每年、每月甚至有时每天需要赚多少钱。你向我解释的事情之一是，这可以解释为什么在下雨的傍晚有时很难叫到出租车。你能告诉我们为什么心理账户可能会让我们在下雨的
evenings? So this is a study that some friends of mine and I did a long time ago in New York and we were taking a lot of cabs and we were talking to the cab drivers and we would ask them, how do you decide how long to work? They rent the cab for 12 hours, which is a long time to drive in Manhattan and then they have to take it back within the 12 hours. And a lot of them would say, well, what we do is I set a target. So renting the cab costs me 100 bucks,
傍晚更难叫到出租车吗？这是我和我的朋友们很久以前在纽约做的一项研究，当时我们坐了很多出租车，我们和出租车司机交谈，我们会问他们，你们是怎么决定工作多长时间的？他们租出租车12个小时，这在曼哈顿开车是很长的时间，然后他们必须在12小时内把车还回去。很多人会说，我们做的是，我设定一个目标。租出租车花了我100美元，
and then I have to fill the tank up. Let's say that's another 25 bucks. So I want to make a certain amount above that, say $100. And when I hit that, I go home. Now, an implication of that is, on days like rainy days, where there's lots of demand, they hit their target early, and they go home. Now, what would an econ do?
然后我必须把油箱加满。假设那是另外25美元。所以我想在此基础上赚取一定的金额，比如100美元。当我达到这个目标时，我就回家。现在，这意味着，在下雨天这样需求很大的日子里，他们很快达到了目标，然后就回家了。现在，“经济人”会怎么做？
An econ would drive more on the busy days. And on the sunny day, when nobody nobody needs a cab because they're walking, you know, he would go out for a walk himself. Again, if we go back to getting along with your spouse, imagine the guy comes home at two in the afternoon and his wife says, how come you're home so early? And he says, because I didn't make any money, right? I mean, this is not going to go over well. No, go on. So you've got to go out there and drive around for three
“经济人”会在生意忙碌的日子里开更多车。而在晴天，当没有人需要出租车因为大家都在走路时，你知道的，他自己会出去散步。同样，如果我们回到和配偶相处的话题，想象一下那个人下午两点回家，他妻子说，你怎么这么早就回家了？他说，因为我没赚到钱，对吧？我的意思是，这不会有什么好结果。不，继续说。所以你必须出去再开三
more hours, burning gas, not making any money. Right. But the interesting thing, of course, is that standard economics would predict that people actually would act rationally, that they would actually work more when the demand is higher, and they would work less when the demand is lower. And of course, what we find is exactly the opposite. Exactly.
个小时的车，烧着油，却没有赚到钱。对。但有趣的是，标准经济学当然会预测人们实际上会理性行事，当需求更高时他们实际上会工作更多，当需求更低时他们会工作更少。当然，我们发现的情况恰恰相反。没错。
One of the interesting implications of mental accounting is that where the source of people's money ends up changing how they spend the money. So there was a study by Viviana Zelliser, I believe at Princeton University, looking at prostitutes in Oslo. And what she found is that the sex workers were willing to spend money that they received in the form of welfare checks or other kinds of subsidies on things like rent and important things. But they spent the money that they earned from sex work. They were far more likely to spend that on drugs and alcohol.
心理账户的一个有趣影响是，人们金钱的来源最终会改变他们如何花这笔钱。所以有一项由普林斯顿大学的薇维亚娜·泽利泽进行的关于奥斯陆性工作者的研究。她发现，这些性工作者愿意把她们以福利支票或其他补贴形式收到的钱花在房租和重要事情上。但她们把通过性工作赚来的钱。她们更有可能把这些钱花在毒品和酒精上。
That the source of the money determines how you actually spend the money. I saw a clip from a video, it's called Welcome to Me, starring the comedian, Kristen Wig, about a woman who suddenly wins a huge amount of money. And I'm going to play the clip for you, and I want you to talk about this idea. So if you could play the video, please. 14, there's 57, 15, and 54, and 39.
金钱的来源决定了你实际上如何花这笔钱。我看到了一个视频片段，叫做《欢迎来到我》，由喜剧演员克里斯汀·韦格主演，讲述了一个突然赢得巨额资金的女人的故事。我要为你播放这个片段，我希望你谈谈这个想法。所以如果你能播放视频，请。14，有57，15，和54，以及39。
Thanks for calling the California lottery. If you're calling to report a winning, just say, I'm a winner at any time. I'm a winner at any time. What's your name? My name is Alice Cleague, I'm $186 million. You truly won the lottery? Seriously? Can someone Google that? You truly won the lottery? Seriously?
感谢致电加利福尼亚彩票。如果您是来报告中奖的，只需随时说，我随时都是赢家。我随时都是赢家。你叫什么名字？我叫爱丽丝·克利格，我中了1.86亿美元。你真的中彩票了？真的吗？有人能谷歌一下吗？你真的中彩票了？真的吗？
Can someone Google that? You must be the big winner. I am rich. Me too. I want to talk to you with me as the host. I'm going to talk about kind of events. No. OK, step to you.
有人能谷歌一下吗？你一定是那个大赢家。我发财了。我也是。我想和你一起做节目，由我来主持。我要谈谈各种事件。不。好的，轮到你了。
I want to talk about it. Me? How much will that cost? $15 million. Oh, and I want to come in on a swan boat. You're off your meds. You're living in a reservation casino and you're hosting your own talk show.
我想谈谈这个。我？那要花多少钱？1500万美元。哦，我想乘天鹅船出场。你没吃药吧。你住在度假村赌场里，还主持你自己的脱口秀。
It's a new era, $86 million. We go live in five, four, three. Where is she now? I think she's a little frozen. You're on TV now. Hello, I'm Al's Cleague, and welcome to me. So Richard, why is this? Why is it that when we receive money from certain sources,
这是一个新时代，8600万美元。我们在五、四、三中直播。她现在在哪里？我想她有点僵住了。你现在在电视上了。你好，我是爱丽丝·克利格，欢迎来到我的世界。所以理查德，这是为什么？为什么当我们从某些来源收到钱时，
the way we think about spending that money changes dramatically? You know, one of my colleagues, my fellow troublemakers, is David Lopes, who's just become the chairman of the Harvard Economics Department. Used to be one of my protegees. Now, you know, anyway. Some of my friends had a roast for me a couple weeks ago because I had a big birthday. And he was telling the following story.
我们思考如何花这笔钱的方式会发生巨大的变化？你知道，我的一个同事，我的同伙，大卫·罗普斯，刚刚成为哈佛大学经济系主任。以前是我的门生之一。现在，你知道，无论如何。几周前，我过了一个大生日，我的几个朋友为我办了一个庆祝会。他当时讲了以下这个故事。
A bunch of us were invited to Washington, must have been 15 years ago, when David was a struggling young assistant professor, and did something for the National Institute of Health, and they gave us a $200 honor a rarium for the day. So I was saying, you know, this is ridiculous. We don't work for $200 a day. We have to go out and spend this money on dinner.
我们一群人被邀请去华盛顿，一定是在15年前，当时大卫还是一个苦苦挣扎的年轻助理教授，为美国国立卫生研究院做了一些事情，他们给我们当天的酬金是200美元。所以我说，你知道，这太荒谬了。我们不为每天200美元工作。我们必须出去把这笔钱花在晚餐上。
And so we went out and had a good dinner. You could get quite a good dinner for $200, 15 years ago. Now David was not happy about spending $200 on dinner, and he now claims it was more like $300 when I got done with the wine. But you know, this was my way of thinking, I'm not going to work for $200, but I'm happy to have a good dinner as a result of helping out the NIH.
所以我们出去吃了一顿好饭。15年前，200美元可以吃到一顿相当不错的晚餐。现在大卫对花200美元吃晚餐很不高兴，他现在声称当我喝完酒后，费用更接近300美元。但你知道，这是我的思维方式，我不会为200美元工作，但我很高兴因为帮助国立卫生研究院而能吃上一顿好晚餐。
Yeah. So, Sadiya Sifan also, for example, that if you want to reward employees at the end of the year, giving them a cash bonus is very different than giving them a vacation. That even though you're giving them the same amount of money, you're giving them, let's say, $500 as the bonus versus $500 as a vacation, people's report being significantly happier when you give them the significantly happier when you give them the vacation than when you give them the cash. Why is that? Well, because if you give them the vacation, they get to go guilt-free. I rediscovered this last week with my daughter and I made a mistake and it's a mistake. I have all the people shouldn't have made,
是的。所以，萨迪亚·西凡也指出，例如，如果你想在年底奖励员工，给他们现金奖金与给他们假期是非常不同的。即使你给他们相同金额的钱，假设你给他们500美元作为奖金与500美元的假期，人们报告说，当你给他们假期时，他们明显比你给他们现金时要快乐得多。为什么会这样？嗯，因为如果你给他们假期，他们可以毫无负罪感地去。我上周和女儿在一起时重新发现了这一点，我犯了一个错误，这是一个错误。我本不该犯所有人都不该犯的错误，
but I had good reasons. And I was well-intentioned. So my daughter's a Metz fan. And one of the Metz pictures happens to be a neighbor. So she was a Metz fan. And I thought it would be nice to buy her two tickets to one of the first round games when her neighbor was pitching.
但我有充分的理由。而且我是出于好意。所以我女儿是麦茨队的球迷。麦茨队的一个投手恰好是邻居。所以她是麦茨队的球迷。我想给她买两张第一轮比赛的门票，当时她的邻居正在投球，这会很棒。
But it was, I got this idea late. So I went online and I found that I could get tickets for about $400. But I didn't have time to buy the tickets and mail them to her. So I sent her an email with a link to this website saying, OK, it looks like you can get tickets for 400 each. I'm going to send you $1,000 by two tickets on this website. And she had already expressed great excitement about getting to go to this game.
但这是，我这个想法来晚了。所以我上网发现我可以买到大约400美元的门票。但我没有时间买票并寄给她。所以我给她发了一封电子邮件，里面带有这个网站的链接，说，好吧，看起来你可以以每张400美元的价格买到票。我要给你1000美元，在这个网站上买两张票。她之前已经对去观看这场比赛表现出极大的兴奋。
So I send her that email. I get back at text. LOL. This is just like one of the examples from your book. If you send me a thousand dollars, I'm not going to spend it on baseball tickets. So now she would have been happy to, had centered the tickets for sure they would have gone to the game, but I send her the $1,000 nothing, so I didn't send her the $1,000. More of my conversation with Behavioral Economist Richard Thaler after this. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam.
所以我给她发了那封邮件。我收到了一个短信。哈哈。这就像你书中的例子之一。如果你给我一千美元，我不会把它花在棒球票上。所以现在她本来会很高兴的，如果把票送给她，他们肯定会去比赛，但我给她一千美元却什么都没有，所以我没有给她一千美元。广告后将继续播出我与行为经济学家理查德·塞勒的对话。这里是“隐藏的大脑”，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。
Back in the 1970s, Stanford psychologist Walter Michelle conducted a series of experiments that came to be known as the Marshmallow Test. Small children were put in a room and told they could either get one marshmallow right away, but if they stayed in the room and didn't eat the marshmallow, they would get a second. Children who tried not to eat the first marshmallow came up with ways to distract themselves. Watching these children on video is hilarious. you. You can either wait and I'll give you another one if you wait or you can eat it now. When I come back I'll give you another one so then you'll have to stay in here and stay in the chair till I come back. I'll play Richard Taylor a video of a marshmallow test in progress where a
早在20世纪70年代，斯坦福大学心理学家沃尔特·米歇尔进行了一系列实验，后来被称为“棉花糖实验”。小孩子们被放在一个房间里，被告知他们可以立即得到一个棉花糖，但如果他们呆在房间里不吃棉花糖，他们会得到第二个。试图不吃第一个棉花糖的孩子们想出了分散自己注意力的方法。在视频中观看这些孩子真是太滑稽了。你。你可以等一下，如果你等的话我会给你另一个，或者你现在就可以吃。当我回来时我会给你另一个，所以你必须一直呆在这里，坐在椅子上直到我回来。我将向理查德·泰勒播放一段正在进行中的棉花糖实验的视频，其中一个
small boy tries desperately not to eat the marshmallow placed in front of him. At one point he leans lovingly into the marshmallow and takes a great big sniff and then sadly looks away. How'd you do? Did you do good? You did? You want to eat it, didn't you? Yeah, so that's how you'd give me another one.
小男孩拼命地试图不吃摆在他面前的棉花糖。有一点，他深情地靠向棉花糖，深深地吸了一口气，然后悲伤地把目光移开。你做得怎么样？你做得好吗？你做了？你想吃它，不是吗？是的，这就是你如何再给我一个。
The excited boy crams both marshmallows chipmunk style into his mouth. So talk about self-control Richard. Why have classical economics ignored the idea that humans have trouble with self-control? So economic theory says that we optimize and that we always choose what's best for us. So that includes self-control. And so in these experiments, if you'd rather have two marshmallows than one, you should be willing to wait 10 minutes. But as, you know, obviously, kids have less self-control than adults.
这个兴奋的男孩像花栗鼠一样把两个棉花糖一股脑塞进嘴里。理查德，谈谈自我控制吧。为什么古典经济学忽视了人类在自我控制方面有困难这一观点？所以经济学理论说我们进行优化，我们总是选择对我们最好的东西。所以这包括自我控制。所以在这些实验中，如果你宁愿要两个棉花糖而不是一个，你应该愿意等10分钟。但正如，你知道，显然，小孩子的自控能力不如成年人。
So this experiment kind of exaggerates that. But what you get from those videos, those precious videos, is the real important idea, which is that self-control is work. Resisting temptation is work. This is important, you know, 30% of Americans are obese. Half of Americans are not saving enough for retirement. So these are enormous problems that we as a society face,
所以这个实验有点夸大了这一点。但你从那些视频中，那些珍贵的视频中得到的，是真正重要的观点，那就是自我控制是工作。抵制诱惑是工作。这很重要，你知道，30%的美国人肥胖。一半的美国人没有为退休存够钱。所以这些是我们作为一个社会面临的巨大问题，
and they are at their core because exerting self-control is difficult. In some of these marshmallow experiments, they used Oreos. And my favorite one of these, in one condition, there was a kid, and he had three Oreos in front of him. And he could have one now, but he was looking at the three. And what he does is as soon as the person leaves the room, he opens up the Oreos, licks
它们的核心在于发挥自我控制是困难的。在其中一些棉花糖实验中，他们使用的是奥利奥。其中我最喜欢的一个，在一个情况下，有一个孩子，他面前有三个奥利奥。他现在可以吃一个，但他看着那三个。他做的是，一离开房间，他就打开奥利奥，舔
out the middle, and then puts them back together. And I have a deep suspicion. These were done many years ago at Stanford. I'm pretty sure that guy is Bernie Madoff. But... LAUGHTER There's interesting work that you've cited by George Lonestein and others looking at the difference between hot and cold emotional states, which is that if you ask me right now, would you be able to resist having dessert at lunch?
掉中间的部分，然后把它们拼回去。我有一个深深的怀疑。这些是多年前在斯坦福完成的。我很确定那家伙是伯尼·马道夫。但是……笑声你曾引用过乔治·洛温斯坦和其他人关于热情绪状态和冷情绪状态之间差异的有趣研究，也就是说，如果你现在问我，你能在午餐时抵制吃甜点的诱惑吗？
I would say, yeah, sure. I can probably resist having dessert at lunch, but an hour and a half from now, when I'm really hungry and I'm sitting down at the table and there's dessert in front of me, the person whom I am at that point is very different than the person I am right now. Right. So, you know, we can all relate to that. We all know the hazards of going to the grocery store hungry. And let's say you're there on Thursday and you missed lunch and it's six o'clock and you're buying dinner not just for tonight, but also for Saturday. Now, your hunger now should not affect the size of the roast you buy for Saturday,
我会说，是的，当然。我可能能够抵制在午餐时吃甜点的诱惑，但在一个半小时后，当我真的很饿，坐在桌子前，面前有甜点时，我那个时候的我和现在的我非常不同。对，所以，你知道，我们都能对此产生共鸣。我们都知道饿着肚子去杂货店的危险。假设你星期四去那里，你错过了午餐，现在是六点钟，你不仅在买今晚的晚餐，还在买周六的晚餐。现在，你现在的饥饿感不应该影响你为周六买的烤肉的大小，
but you'll buy a bigger roast. Yeah. The other thing, of course, we often do sometimes when we have problems with self-control is that we try and have an external enforcer. We try and appoint somebody who will help us run that kind of self-control is that we try and have an external enforcer. We try and appoint somebody who will help us run that kind of self-control. This of course goes back to the old idea, the myth of the Fulicis who was sailing by the sirens.
但你会买更大的烤肉。是的。当然，我们在自控力出现问题时经常做的另一件事是，我们尝试有一个外部执行者。我们试图指派某人来帮助我们运行这种自我控制。我们尝试指派某人来帮助我们运行这种自我控制。这当然可以追溯到古老的观点，即尤利西斯航行通过塞壬的神话。
He was afraid that he was going to drift close to the sirens. And so Eulisis had his men bind him to the mast of his ship so that they would be able to sail close to the sirens. And here the sirens song without actually being tempted to go toward the sirens So people have tried variations of this and all kinds of things are trying to address are the temptations that we expect to face in the future I came by a very nice clip from the TV show Curb your enthusiasm Where Larry David is essentially asked to be the enforcer for one of his friends take a look at the clip So yeah hungry starving good is essentially asked to be the enforcer for one of his friends. Take a look at the clip. So, you hungry?
他害怕自己会漂流到靠近塞壬的地方。所以尤利西斯让他的手下把他绑在船的桅杆上，这样他们就能航行靠近塞壬。并在没有真正受到诱惑去走向塞壬的情况下听到塞壬的歌声。所以人们尝试了这种方法的变体，以及各种各样的事情，试图解决我们预期在未来会面临的诱惑。我偶然看到一个来自电视剧《抑制热情》的非常好的片段，其中拉里·戴维基本上被要求成为他朋友之一的执行者，看看这个片段。所以，是的，饿得要死。好，我们有一顿丰盛的饭。
It's starving. Good, we got a great meal. And some fabulous desserts. Which, by the way, I need you to keep me away from no matter what. Oh, OK. Yeah? Because I put a lot of time into this. I need a dessert referee.
还有一些美妙的甜点。顺便说一句，不管怎样，我需要你阻止我靠近它们。哦，好吧。是吗？因为我在这个上面花了很多时间。我需要一个甜点裁判。
All right, I'm your guy. You promise? Yeah, I promise. OK, I'm counting. All right. Ah. Ah. No, no, no, no. I'm just going to have a bite. Oh, no, Okay, I'm counting. All right. Ha ha ha ha. No, no, no, no, no.
好吧，我是你的人。你保证？是的，我保证。好吧，我在数数。好的。啊。啊。不，不，不，不。我只吃一口。哦，不，好吧，我在数数。好吧。哈哈哈哈。不，不，不，不。
I'm just going to have a bite. Oh, no, no, no, no, no. Just a bite, come on. You know what? You told me specifically not to let you have any dessert. I appreciate it, Larry, but I changed my mind. Yes, yes, yes. But you said no matter what.
我只吃一口。哦，不，不，不，不，不。就一口，来吧。你知道吗？你明确告诉过我不要让你吃任何甜点。我很感激，拉里，但我改变主意了。是的，是的，是的。但你说过不管怎样。
But you know what, I'm changing it. And this is now I'm saying, thank you for helping me. I'm going to have some care. No, no, but you can't change it. That's why you say no matter what. But you know what, I'm changing it, and this is now I'm saying thank you for helping me. I'm gonna have some care. No, no, but you can't change it. That's why you say no matter what. This is the what. But now what? That's why you asked me and not these other people
但你知道吗，我改变了。现在我在说，谢谢你帮我。我要吃一点。不，不，但你不能改变。这就是为什么你要说不管怎样。但你知道吗，我改变了，现在我在说谢谢你帮我。我要吃一点。不，不，但你不能改变。这就是为什么你要说不管怎样。这就是那个不管怎样。但现在呢？这就是为什么你找我而不是其他人
because you knew I wouldn't let you. What would it look? Larry, you told me that to Larry. Oh, yeah. I said I was. She said no matter what. Okay. Oh, no.
因为你知道我不会让你吃。会是什么样？拉里，你告诉过拉里的。哦，是的。我说过了。她说不管怎样。好吧。哦，不。
No, no. No. No. No. No. No. He said no matter what, okay. Oh, no, no dessert in the face, you know, let me add it. Thank you all so much and thanks Richard Taylor. That was Behavioral Economist Richard Taylor. His latest book is called Misbehaving, the Making of Behavioral Economics. This week's show was produced by Karamagar Galeson, Maggie Pennman and Max Nestrak. Our team includes Tara Boyle, Raina Cohen, Parts Shah, Jennifer Schmidt and Renee Clarre. Our Ronsang heroes this week are Adam Osman, Nikki Strickland, Thomas Bussey, and Don Gooden. Adam, Nikki, Thomas, and Don work on our facilities team here at NPR,
不，不。不。不。不。不。不。他说不管怎样，好吧。哦，不，不要把甜点糊在脸上，你知道，让我吃一口。非常感谢大家，也感谢理查德·泰勒。那是行为经济学家理查德·泰勒。他的最新书叫《错误的行为：行为经济学的制造》。本周的节目由卡拉马加·加勒森、玛吉·佩恩曼和马克斯·内斯特拉克制作。我们的团队包括塔拉·博伊尔、雷娜·科恩、帕茨·沙、詹妮弗·施密特和蕾妮·克拉雷。我们本周的幕后英雄是亚当·奥斯曼、尼基·斯特里克兰、托马斯·布西和唐·古登。亚当、尼基、托马斯和唐在我们NPR的设施团队工作，
and they recently helped us move to a new floor of the building. They intuitively understood how important a good work space is to be creative and productive. They put in long hours, including on the weekend, and helped us pack, unpack, and get settled in our new space. I'm so grateful for their hard work. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
他们最近帮助我们搬到了大楼的新楼层。他们凭直觉理解了一个好的工作空间对于富有创造力和生产力是多么的重要。他们付出了长时间的工作，包括周末，并帮助我们打包、拆包并在新空间安顿下来。我非常感谢他们的辛勤工作。这个剧集还没有评论。点击文字记录中的任何句子来留下评论。